the original
situation send it to the state
traditionally for infectious diseases
that kind of approach works
what is clear man it doesn't work it's
essentially blind that the country with
it the only way that works is if you get
the private sector involved some of the
standard companies that make the
diagnostic test that you I get when we
go for regular visit to a physician they
have been engaged right now the FDA the
CDC all of the government agencies the
secretary himself secretary Hayes has
been very much involved in working with
that group to be able to get that revved
up really quickly you know I hate to
give dates on things but what I'm
hearing from the taskforce meeting that
I just left that that should very likely
happen within the next week or so it's
not gonna be months it's gonna be a week
or so were you're gonna get many many
more tests that will be available but
the other thing that's important and
there was a considerable amount of
misunderstanding about that that the
original guidelines for whether you
could get a test was somewhat
restrictive the FDA has now removed
those restrictions you know it was part
of the thing was well yeah that been
either in contact with someone or or
very closely geographically
at risk for infection now that's not the
case you go to a doctor if you have
symptoms that are suggestive of the
corona virus it doesn't matter where you
are you know you have to take it by a
state-by-state basis the one thing I do
advise that I've said this at multiple
hearings and briefings that right now we
have to start implementing both
containment and mitigation and what was
done when you do closer to school this
mitigation we've got to try as best as
we can to distance ourselves from each
other particularly if you are within a
group that are at higher risk if you do
get infected you're gonna have a
complication those are the elderly
people with underlying conditions
chronic congestive heart failure heart
disease lung disease kidney disease
biddies particularly among those if
you're an elderly with that so those are
the kind of things we need to do now and
the point that i was trying to make is
that we don't want to wait until you get
a lot of infections because sometimes
when you do make it whether it be
marilyn whatever they did you make a
decision to do something and someone
might say well are you overreacting we
got a we got to lose that we gotta start
looking at doing things now in
anticipation of what might happen and
the reason is if you look at infectious
diseases how they work particularly
outbreaks of new infections they go like
this then they go like this and then
they shoot up like that and if you look
at the curves of the history of
outbreaks they have these sharp peak and
then they started coming down if you
look at what happened in China that's
exactly what happened it's starting to
have a little bit now in Korea the
purpose and the goal of both containment
and mitigation is to instead of making
it go up like that
blunt did so it goes like that you're
never gonna suppress it completely so we
have to get used to we're going to get
infections probably a lot more
infectious I think absolutely
I believe if we did not do that with
China early on well alright well I think
that was a prudent choice we spent a lot
of time thinking about it
discussing it about whether we should do
it and it was the right public health
call and here's the numerical reason why
if you look back early on Chinese
travelers who are infected seated not
only the United States but countries in
Europe including Italy if you look today
at the majority of cases that are new
cases not old ones new cases throughout
the world the majority of them are from
Europe Europe to other countries if you
look in the united states and states
that have new cases the majority of them
are coming from that region it was based
on that that the travel restriction was
suggested and accepted
I'm sorry it's one of the standards were
being tested
and like I said I am NOT going to
comment on individual who has a very
competent position and the White House
position